sie werden gleich sehen wir legen wert
auf interdisziplinäre lehre um um das
auch physisch darzustellen bin ich
präsident
sie hatten ja schon gesagt ich bin arzt
herr lang ist physiker aber eher lang
wird den vortrag halten ich halte mich
dann zurück und sie sehen rona gerecht
wir haben ja eine plexiglasscheibe
zwischen uns installiert und die ist
sogar von der firma tonius zertifiziert
kann also nichts schief genau so dann
starten wir mal also unser vortrag den
haben wir dann nutzen von leer räumen
mit doppel- oder e h für die
interdisziplinäre forschungsnahe lehre
genannt vielleicht kann man es auf der
tafel sehen die wir hier im hintergrund
haben wir wollen aus dem doppel aus den
lehrräumen eine lehre leerraum mitmachen
das ist unser ansinnen und jetzt haben
wir schon einen pädagogischen teil von
der frau gehört
erlebnispädagogik unsere hoffnung ist
vielleicht so eine art hochschule und
erlebnispädagogik umzusetzen und das
wollen wir mit den folgenden themen tun
also die lehrräume wollen wir in der
rolle gern umwandeln
aber dazu einen projekt ins leben
gerufen was vor allem die
wissenschaftliche digitale kompetenzen
adressiert und dabei sich
interdisziplinärer in der
professioneller internationaler lehre
bedient um die rollen gerne nach
deutschland prinzip die forschung lehre
wieder enger aneinander bringen
dann fangen wir mal an die lehrräume das
gehen wir jetzt nicht unbedingt als
physische örtliche physikalische
lehrräume sondern eher als mieter
physisch oder mental leer räumen
also das sind räume für unser
verständnis die natürlich von dem
fachgebiet von den inhalten abhängen
aber auch von denen technik gewarnt
werden einerseits aber auch von den
techniken die wir für die lehre zur
verfügung haben also sehen von der tafel
über den overhead projektor bis hin zu
den smartphones jeder in der hosentasche
hat aber auch die anforderungen an die
studierenden aber auch die beruflichen
anforderungen und die rahmenbedingungen
als wo welche kapazitäten oder älter in
der lehre zur verfügung stehen
ja wie können wir diesen diesen wandel
gerecht werden mit statischen strukturen
studium wie könnte eine notwendige
flexibilität für den beruf gewährleisten
wie schon angedeutet das smartphone als
das wissen in der hosentasche haben wir
aktuell wer weiß was in fünf zehn 20
jahren der fall ist geht das berufsleben
sich entwickelt wird und nie kann
praktisch die lehre auch agil diese
dinge adressieren
ja da wollten wir ganz gerne noch einmal
vorweg schicken ein sehr schönes
statement für unseren geschmack von den
oecd bildungsministern ich lese es
gerade mal vor auf englisch sustainable
development and social gerieten die pen
critically und competencies operation
das kompetenz is understood to cover
knowledge and skills das kennen wir aber
auch und das sind die schönen attitudes
and values und naja die attitudes &
values verraten ist an mancher stelle
gibt es einfach änderungsbedarf in der
lehre und ein umdenken ist erforderlich
und da haben wir hier noch mal ein bild
mitgebracht was so ein bisschen diese
aspekte situiertes lernen darstellt
nämlich von multiplen perspektiven die
wichtig sind siege lehre darstellung von
komplexen und auch arbeiten an komplexen
problemen und damit verbunden natürlich
auch die eigene artikulation und
reflektion authentizität eine wichtige
rolle
was natürlich auch immer im sozialen
austausch basiert das heißt wir wollen
weg von der und lehre hin wirklich ins
geschehen da wo die forschung
stattfindet wollen wir gerne mit der
lehre teilhaben
stichwort ist da auch natürlich der
wechsel vom teaching zum learning aus
sicht der studierenden
und hier haben wir dargestellt
verschiedene aspekte beziehungsweise
punkte die das begriffen sie sehen dass
das fachwissen bei diesen tortendiagramm
nur einen kleinen teil ausmache
es gibt auch noch ganz viele andere
aspekte nämlich das anwenden das
integrieren also die eigenen
zusammenhänge herstellen das menschliche
spielt eine rolle
natürlich auch petit & value ii was
hingehört haben die werte und natürlich
müssen die künftige absolventen auch
einen lernen selbst lernen wie wir
sicherlich an vierter stelle brauchen
und das auch schon wissen
und ja wenn man das berücksichtigt
leicht erreicht man damit ein
flexibleres nicht so statisches
facettenreiches studium und anhand des
änderungsbedarf merkt man schnell dass
verschiedene lehrräume in der
hochschullehre existieren und die sehen
wir insbesondere zwischen den
disziplinen aber auch zwischen
berufsgruppen das heißt ein puzzle ist
nur mit allen puzzlestücken das große
ganze zwischen theorie den büchern und
der praxis zum beispiel im labor
zwischen ausbildung und berufsleben wie
schon gesagt aber auch hierarchisch dass
man über hierarchien die lehre spannend
und alle voneinander lernen lässt da
hatte das wissenschaftliche arbeiten
treibt uns um und da haben wir hier noch
ein bild mitgebracht was zum denken
anregt nämlich wie man das forschen gut
oder auf welche weise man das forschen
vermitteln kann und sie sehen also der
linken seite ist der schwerpunkt auf den
inhalten der forschung auf der rechten
seite ist der schwerpunkt auf dem
prozess forschen selbst und dann stellt
sich noch die frage sind die studenten
wie unten nur zuhörer eines
forschungsprozesses oder sind sie
tatsächlich mit teilnehmende und aktive
oder touristen in der realität haben wir
oft dass
links untere feld wie sap in hand und
unser ansehen ist es in jedem fall als
auch research to dort nach dieser
nomenklatur zu lehren beziehungsweise
auch die anderen felder mehr mehr zu
bedienen
ja wie kann man das umsetzen
welchen modalitäten gibt es vorlesungen
seminare labor explosion praktikum
tagung all dies trägt dazu bei um die
verschiedenen kompetenzen zu schulen
das ist jetzt hier ein älteres bild man
sollte vielleicht mittlerweile die
digitalen modalitäten verschiedene
lehrer leer format das selbststudium
online gruppen arbeiten oder während der
lehrer feedback und status werkzeuge
learning analytics mit hinzufügen die
natürlich auch wiederum dringend
benötigte kompetenzen adressieren und
all das ist wichtig aber es stellt sich
immer die frage wie kann man zum
beispiel einen merkwürdigen verschrobene
wissenschaftler an den klinisch aktiven
engagierten arzt bringen in unserem fall
zum beispiel unserem projekt
naturwissenschaft und technik in der
medizin ist das oft ein großer punkt die
ärzte müssen patienten helfen haben
keine zeit die wissenschaftler sind oft
nur idealisten im labor
wir müssen sie aber zusammenführen um
vorbehalte oder missverständnisse
auszuräumen
das heißt das soll so eine art kleine
liebe entstehen das wollen wir mit
unseren lehrveranstaltungen erreichen ja
und dafür haben holger und ich das
projekt naturwissenschaft und technik in
der medizin ins leben gerufen eben um
die kommunikation und das verständnis
zwischen diesen bereichen zu fördern um
zu sensibilisieren für einen kritischen
und selbstverantwortlichen umgang mit
technik und neuen und vor allem auch
digitalen methoden ja und auch müsse die
kreativität in richtung wissenschaft und
forschung dafür hat dann dazu konnten
wir drei fachbereiche an universitäten
diesen gewinnen auf
förderung haben wir dafür erlangt also
dann wenn naturwissenschaftlich
fachbereich mathematik und physik
informatik insbesondere und chemie und
biologie
sowohl eben der fachbereich medizin und
zusammen mit den studierenden dieser
fachbereiche gemeinsam nach der seminare
labor kurse vorlesung studienprojekte
und explosionen und das war wirklich
eine re live experience eine
authentische in der disziplin ehren in
der professionelle kooperation seien mit
experten der lokalen
forschungslandschaft und ein paar dieser
experten haben wir jetzt exemplarisch
mal dargestellt zum beispiel sofia 1 sie
arbeiten der kernphysik vorstands
superschweren elementen und
kernreaktionen und das hat unmittelbar
auch medizinischen zusammenhang
beziehungsweise eine verwandtschaft und
da haben wir in marburg das gehört zu
unserem universitätsklinikum das
sogenannte jürgen strahlentherapie
zentrum da ist es ganz wichtig zu
verstehen bei puma bestrahlungen welche
neben reaktionen finden der stadt und
wie schädigend mag das zb für patienten
sein welche optimierungsprozesse gibt es
da also sie sehen die disziplinen kommen
dann schon doch sehr schnell zusammen
zwischen medizin und sie sich in diesem
fall ja dann haben wir zum beispiel den
markus thoma sie sehen hier ein bild in
der mitte
er forscht an raumfahrttechnik und
plasmaphysik bei einem parabelflug
machte dass man experimente die zum
beispiel auch auf der iss eingesetzt
werden und naja der medizinische
zusammenhang wäre da zum beispiel die
plasmamedizin wo man mit einem
atmosphärischen plasma keine
inaktivieren kann was aber oft ist es
eine wichtige rolle spielt damit die mal
gesagt nicht vergammelt so unser willst
ja professor uwe lange ein internist und
rheumatologe ist auch sehr unterschieden
unserem
forschungsprojekt auf verschiedene art
und weisen und da haben wir gemeinsam
mit dem markus thoma einer studie ins
leben gerufen mit einem ethik antrag der
deutschen genehmigt ist da geht es um
die behandlung von klärung der nie
patienten ist eine seltene erkrankung
und wir wollen mit diesem plasma diese
raten bis nicht großen diese operation
an den fingern behandeln und schauen die
da die wundheilung besser vonstatten
geht das als beispiel gesehen aus der
forschung ins seminar und tatsächlich
auch wieder in die forschung hinein
france termin from science seminar zu
sein es ist der slogan ja zum aktuellen
geschehen
die digitale offensive
bislang war das immer eine didaktische
studie aus wertvolle ergänzung natürlich
philip glass um methoden inverter
classroom aber auch learning analytics
aktuell durch das pandemie geschehen ist
es natürlich ein must-have wir müssen
also die präsenz lehre aktueller setzen
und wir haben uns mal ketzerisch so
beiden lehrer genannt weil viele
lehrende kämpfen einfach ums überleben
der lehre um abschlüsse zu gewährleisten
um den fortschritt in unserem fall im
studium zu gewährleisten
aber da steht man nicht ganz allein auf
weiter flur da gibt es bundesweit einige
hilfestellungen die einmal aufgezeigt
aus dem hochschul forum digitalisierung
so ein paar tricks tipps für die
digitale lehre oder auch von seiten der
gema gesellschaft für medizinische
ausbildung einen ausschluss in dem ich
auch die ich bin
der hat so eine linksammlung unsere
digitale tools zur verfügung gestellt ja
und diese lehrmethoden die wir aktuell
bedienen die haben natürlich auch
parallelen wiederum zur medizin also
distance learning und telemedizin
naja spielt mit ähnlichen spielregeln
es gibt viele
einheitliche oder ähnliche aspekte also
zum beispiel wie können wir
kommunizieren über video audio oder
irgendwelche chat funktionen machen wir
das sinken also wir wollen sagen die
lehre und die digitale lehre diesem
monat stattfindet findet sich auch
wiederum in der telemedizin und das
ganze aufzugreifen und nicht nur die
digitale lehre als selbstzweck zu nutzen
sondern auch kreativ zu nutzen wie
können wir das für die aktuelle oder für
die künftige medizin nutzen das ist so
ein bisschen unser betrieb und was man
natürlich auch immer wieder betonen muss
in der lehre nicht nur online und
digital unterricht sondern bitter die
brief modelle
wir brauchen auch präsenz sie brauchen
praktische fertigkeiten wir müssen die
psyche motorischen fertigkeiten einfach
üben
deshalb kann man sich die frage stellen
praktische fertigkeiten durch online
simulationen 1 kommt der digitale das
medizinstudium in malta bringt uns dass
mediziner und medizinerinnen hier
passiert am patienten arbeiten können
man mag zweifeln sie sind der meinung
natürlich brauchen wir auch praktische
tätigkeiten und dafür gibt es die hybrid
modelle 1er zielführendes beispiel
wollen wir hier mal zeigen was zuletzt
an der kinderklinik an unserer
universitätsklinikum diesen durchgeführt
wurde ein digitaler livestream
unterricht am krankenbett
der arzt und oder die ärztin und die
patienten patientinnen werden über
mobile endgeräte praktisch gestreamt zu
den studierenden die können einer
untersuchung oder eine therapie
beiwohnen und können auch fragen stellen
beziehungsweise auf fragen antworten die
die lehrenden an sie stellen und
interessant oder wichtig wäre dabei auch
um den ablauf zu verbessern und um die
situation zu entspannen das auch die
patienten und patientinnen eine sicht
auf die studierenden haben um eine
gewisse authentizität um transparenz
herzustellen
und an der stelle sollten wir auf jeden
fall sagen
fried veranstaltung sind sehr sehr
zweckdienlich auch im sinne von inverted
glas von methoden eben um die knappe
kostbare präsenz lehrer zu unterstützen
und noch wertvoller zu machen
zum thema wird praktische fertigkeiten
wollten wir gerne noch erzählen dass wir
im letzten jahr bei dem 30-jährigen
partnerschafts beginn unserer und wer
sie ergießen und unser partner
universität in kasan einen virtuellen
campus ins leben gerufen haben bei dem
wir ein gemeinsames master modul
umsetzen wollen
und da geht es eben darum dass wir mit
videokonferenzen mit online seminaren
einen virtuellen raum schaffen in dem
wir verschiedene kurse durchführen
können und die teilnehmer interagieren
sich kennen lernen zusammen diskutieren
und dann aber auch zusammen experimente
machen teilweise in präsenz aber
teilweise mit lacroix stream zu der
entsprechenden partneruniversität um das
praktische auch viel mehr online
greifbar zu machen also das sehen wir
als sehr interdisziplinär und in der
professionellen wie in der kulturell was
also wertvolle attribute sind ja das ist
natürlich von unserem projekt
unterstützt und sollte dieses auch ein
bisschen spiegeln aber es braucht auch
noch mehr formate weitere formate wie zb
diese schlagwörter wie können sie
intelligenz augmented reality virtual
die mixed reality bedienen und dazu
haben wir das seit 2009 10 eine
vorlesung künstliche intelligenz
methoden mal anna lena könig und martin
obert die das maßgeblich gestaltet und
begleitet haben und diesen leer format
haben wir tatsächlich medizinstudierende
mathematik physik biologie studierende
aber auch rechtswissenschaften
und geschichtswissenschaften und sie
können sich vorstellen dass da
tatsächlich viele diskussionen aufkommen
und man sehr viel voneinander lernen
kann natürlich von den technischen unten
über die anwendungsmöglichkeiten von 15
intelligenz aber auch und das findet
auch sehr interessant über die ethischen
aspekte
das muss man sich nämlich auch mal zu
gemüte führen also wir haben was in dem
comic mal lustig dargestellt der
wissenschaftler oder arzt erklärt dem
computer was gut ist und was schlecht
ist gut ist es den krebs zu heilen
schlecht ist es die weltherrschaft an
sich zu reißen
ja aber was ist denn überhaupt gut und
das ist schlecht
das ist gar nicht so ganz klar es klar
zu sagen und da gibt es mittlerweile
eine reihe von kompletten auch von
offizieller seite die dies thematisieren
und irgendwie greifbar machen wollen
aber man muss auch sagen dass diese
tatsächlich sehr spät kommen und immer
nicht komplett sind also da gibt es in
den regen diskussionsbedarf und die
leute die nach ihrem abschluss im
berufsleben stehen sollten wirklich
fähig sein und fit sein
diese aspekte auch selbst zu
reflektieren mehr mehr spielen auch die
berbens und die smartphones natürlich
eine rolle
gerade im ärztlichen alltag zum beispiel
mit deren smart watches die
vorhofflimmern detektieren können oder
eine kurze mitri vornehmen können ja die
ärzte müssen darauf reagieren können und
müssen erklären wo es in die
chancenlosen die grenzen dieser
möglichkeiten und da hat professor
christian kessel kurzerhand ein neues
wahlfach ins leben gerufen in der
disziplin er gesundheitsökonomie bei dem
studierende ziehen wie man so eine app
programmieren kann
unter dem slogan eigene app in 90
minuten und lernen dabei die
hintergründe und auch die systeme etwas
einzuschätzen
weiterhin haben wir ein neues fass ins
leben gerufen das werden wir vermied mit
reality in der medizin
was auch multidisziplinär stattfindet
und stattfinden soll
mit teilnehmenden aus allen möglichen
fachbereichen und fächern darum dabei
geht es uns nicht nur um die leher
szenarien in unserem fall zum beispiel
anatoli lernen oder op es ruhig führen
sondern es geht auch darum die technik
selbst zu thematisieren und dann für
künftige forschungen oder für künstliche
behandlungen nutzbar zu machen
und da gibt es tatsächlich auch bereits
schon studien die laufen nämlich mit
schulungen an patienten und personal die
vielleicht die ein besseres
medizinisches aufgaben sorgen und das
ganze haben wir auch schon in der
professionellen durchgeführt also mit
medizinstudierenden und mit
auszubildenden chirurgie technischen
technisch auszubildenden und haben da
verschiedene gemeinsame apps
durchgeführt hier kann man zum beispiel
eine knie-op sehen im virtuellen raum
die habe ich gemacht also falls sie mal
wer darf hätten ich fühle mich da jetzt
gewappnet so gerne er sich melden
ja natürlich kann man zusammen lernen
anatomie strukturen zum beispiel aber
auch die abläufe und das notwendige
instrumentarium kann man in der
professionell erlernen und die
rückmeldungen waren sehr fantastisch wir
hatten zum beispiel zitate wie ja da
steht man 100 mal bei so einer op dabei
aber noch nie hat man wirklich mal ins
op fällt in das operationsfeld
reingeschaut und hat überhaupt gesehen
was da passiert und da mag virtuelle
realität methode sein um diesen dieser
kluft etwas bei leibe zu rücken
und auch hier muss man sagen es ist
durchaus interessant was geschieht in
der lehre und tatsächlich ist das wieder
interessant für unsere forschung für
unsere lehrer forschung wie können wir
diese formate gestalten wo ist der
lernzuwachs wo
der bedarf und was ergibt sich daraus
wieder und ja damit können wir
eigentlich zu unserem risiko lehrräume
und leerräume können gestaltet werden
ich hoffe oder wir hoffen das konnten
wir ihnen zeigen
es bedarf natürlich eine anpassung oder
umorientierung der lehre in richtung
kompetenzen in der disziplin arid und
inter professionalität aber auch zum fit
machen für den arbeitsmarkt natürlich
die internationalität in einer globalen
der letzten welt und wir wollen immer
gerne die verbindung in der lehre aber
auch die thematisierung von digitaler
technik passieren
virtuell und real um unser stichwort und
wir konnten ihn hoffentlich zeigen dass
tatsächlich die idee von der
wissenschaft in die lehre in die
wissenschaft und die forschung
funktionieren kann natürlich haben wir
noch ein paar dinge zu tun wir müssen
unsere lehrer formale weiterentwickeln
es fehlt außerdem neue prüfungsformen
kompetenzorientierte prüfen formate zu
entwickeln und auch so mancher
studiengang sollte daran angepasst
werden
insgesamt halten wir es mit der lehre
wie mit der küche regional und saisonal
aber auch in der national inspiriert
damit ach so ja genau
die frage stellt sich noch wer kann das
nicht machen ja also wir beide unsere
unterstützer und protagonistinnen
natürlich wer kann es noch tun sie alle
als lehrende und damit wollen wir uns
jetzt bedanken die ihre aufmerksamkeit
für die möglichkeit den vortrag zu
halten und natürlich bei unseren
partnern im projekt bei unseren
geldgebern
vielen dank und wir freuen uns auf
fragen und diskussionen